is your boss driving them crazy are you
just living from paycheck to paycheck
party to party and everything is just
getting tiring it's gettin played out
and you're asking yourself what's this
all about what's the purpose many people
don't reflect like I'm why am I here
you're born to die and then what do you
got in between me it's a big drama some
days are good some days are bad some
days you're sick some days you're sad we
not we might not make it to 85 years old
we might not make it till tomorrow and
this is something that we need to think
about the lights will go on after the
party and the party will end and you
will be alone and you will have to be
accountable for everything you've done
life is not all about just chasing that
man or woman or that good time it's not
all about the baseball game in the
basketball game and chasing a position
and getting a lot of wealth and money
there's more to dis life and it's up to
you to be sincere enough within yourself
and to want to know more what's the
purpose what's it all about like
many og beloved up the zoo world
many OG beloved up the sewer one woman
in Jersey